bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
pour ce tout nouveau webinaire le numéro
16 et cette semaine nous allons aborder
l'analyse de ces camps sont sur humaines
et sociales ce sera donc plutôt une
introduction en fait l année les
conséquences basé sur un des chapitres
d'analyseurs qui avait été écrit le
départ à part nicolas robben sur le blog
hypothèse point org
nous on va nous permettre d'aborder il
voit les grands principes de cette
analyse des séquences et puis on y
reviendra par la suite puisque dans les
prochaines semaines nous allons aborder
en fait un exemple concret d'analystes
biographique à partir d'analysés
trajectoire de soins et on va aborder ce
même matériel là avec plusieurs
techniques d'analysé de l'analyse survie
de l'analyse séquence des modèles de
régression multi nominaux des modèles
observations répétées
il est peut-être même un modèle sur les
multi est un ainsi que des modèles mix à
15 l'attendait donc du coup on pourra
réaborder l'analyse de séquences de
manière un peu plus complexe dans le cas
de cet exemple qui nous tiendra en
haleine dans les prochaines semaines je
vous propose de commencer tout de suite
et de charge et l'interface de un studio
et la première chose que nous allons
faire déjà ça va être de charger le jeu
de données qui va nous servir pour
aujourd'hui je voulais déposées sur le
site a alors sur le site des webinaires
là vous êtes un sur le site analyseur ce
qu'on va aborder aujourd'hui c'est dans
le menu analyser et analyse séquence où
vous retrouverez du court ce qu'on va
aborder au cours de la journée il pour
récupérer les données du jour je vous
propose d'aller sur le site web in her
accessible ici
si j'avais dans le menu séance on va
retrouver la séance d'aujourd'hui
et notamment un fichier de données qui
s'appelle trash propoints csv donc on va
aller l'enregistrer et je me
l'enregistrer directement dans le
répertoire de travail webinaire 16 que
j'ai déjà créé pour aujourd'hui dans les
studios et avant et on va déjà chargé
données pour voir de quoi est ce qu'on
est en train de parler on va tirer tout
de suite et un nouveau script et où tu
te sauver on va lui donner un titre
comme toujours on va télécharge va
charger un certain nombre de librairies
qui vont nous être utile donc je vais
déjà commencer
comme à chaque fois par chargé de taille
diverse et la bête le fichier qui nous
intéresse est un fichier au format csv
les format csv peuvent importer dans un
studio avec le package rider qui a déjà
été chargé avec le tailles diverses
et puis si on veut profiter d'une
interface interactive
on a toujours dans l'ombre et
environnement le bouton in pauthe
dataset donc les fichiers csv comme à
cette politique valeo soit un type de
fichier texte je vais donc choisi un
point texte widder je vais aller choisir
du coup mon objet trash proches point
csv
donc là les données on va aller on va
les stocker dans un objet qu'on va
appeler donné pour l'exemple aujourd'hui
on voit un contrat en fait un ensemble
de variables qui s'appelle de ce sp1 un
csp 37 et 1 et génération ils sont tous
connaissent une forme numérique
en tout cas il a bien reconnu les
colonnes il a bien reconnu et des
limiteurs donc on voit qu'on a juste
besoin du code
ici donc je vais cliquer sur le petit
bouton copier-coller permet de copier
mon code je vais faire comme ça et je
vais aller coller mon code dans les
faits j'ai pas besoin de recharger
grieder j'ai pas besoin du biou donc je
veux juste garder le donner et je vais
utiliser mon code 1 et puis on va tout
de suite regardé notre jeu de données
donc nous avons mis observations de 38
colonnes on voit que les colonnes sont
toutes sous une forme numérique est en
fait pour vous présenter un petit peu
plus si elle est sûre je ne donnais en
fait ce jeu donné reconstruit à partir
d'une enquête qui a été menée en france
lille en quête de biographies entourage
menée par l'ined en 2000 les carrières
professionnelles 2001 donc ce sont mille
hommes qui ont 50 ans ou plus et ça
reproduit à l'imposition indiquant fait
pour chaque homme
la position professionnelle de l'âge de
14 ans jusqu'à sa canton cette position
est codé la manière suivante les codes 1
6 dans chacune des variables csp
correspondent aux groupes
socioprofessionnels et la démocrature
des pcs de l'insee 13 agriculteurs
exploitants artisans commerçants et
chefs d'entreprise
car notre profession intellectuelle
supérieure professions intermédiaires
employés où il
on y ajouter un code 7 pour les
personnes pour étude inconduite pour une
activité et un code 9 pour le service
militaire
le fichier de données comporte
actuellement une ligne par individu et
une colonne par année la variable csp 1
correspond à la position à 14 ans la
variable csp2 à la position à 15 ans et
c'est bien par ailleurs les enquêtes
étant tous nés entre 1930 et 1950 il y a
une dernière variable la variable
génération qui apprend modalités et qui
econnaît un point génération 1939 138,2
pour la génération 1939 et 1940 1945 et
quand les générations 1946 à 1950 au
final la base est donc constitué de 500
lignes et de 38 colonnes et à ceux
présents du coup sous la forme de ce
fichier texte
alors ce qu'on va faire par exemple en
premier lieu on voi actuellement que
tout et koné sous des formes sous des
formes qui sont sous des formes
numériques et on va faire un petit peu
de travail pour remettre tout ça en
forme donc en premier lieu on va
recoller la variable génération pour en
faire un facteur est donc ce que je vais
mettre dans mon facteur c'est donc me
variable génération mais différentes
valeurs mais niveau
c'est donc un deux trois et je vais
mettre les étiquettes qui correspondent
à ces trois valeurs plus précisément
1930 38 pour la première génération 1939
1945 pour la deuxième génération et 1946
50 1950 pour la troisième génération
en faisant ça si je fais un petit donner
le confort pour la variable génération
vous allez voir que c'est maintenant
recoder en facteur une variable donc
catégorielles avec trois valeurs 1930
1938 1939 1945 1946 simon 150 l'idée
d'une analyse de séquences ça va être de
représenter nos données l'idée c'est que
la trajectoire professionnelle d'un
individu tout au long de sa vie un peu
être représentés du coup par sept succès
une succession d'états est donc là pour
un individu sa trajectoire
professionnelle ça avec la succession
d'états 1 1 1 1 1 1 6 6 6 6 et ainsi de
suite donc on va avoir ses 35 valeurs
qui vont indiquer le parcours de cet
individu pour définit alors pour
travailler avec des données de séquences
donc ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est ce
qu'on appelait si la trajectoire
professionnelle c'est la succession
d'états et pour ça on va avoir besoin
d'un package qu'est le package pour
l'analyse séquence qui s'appelle
traminer donc je vais tout de suite le
charger à partir du moment où les
données sont dans un format large
c'est-à-dire avec une seule ligne par
l'individu et à une colonne pour chaque
pied chacun des packs temps là nous
avons des patent de 20 ans tout est fait
à départ année on va pouvoir faire une
séquence est une séquence en fait elle
se détermine par un alphabet alors ici
nous avons un alphabet qui est en fait
numérique avec 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 auquel
on va pouvoir associer les étiquettes
donc je vais tout de suite de créer un
petit objet qui va contenir un dd
divisée
qu est ce parce que 1 2 3 4 6 et 8 9
s'est pas forcément très très pratique
pour cent pour son souvenir et donc du
coup je vais créer un objet de rappeler
la belle ce jeu fait un vecteur nommé
qui va avoir un petit concours est un
monde d'accord donc par exemple je vais
faire agric égale donc à cliquer pour
alto qui est le lacanau vie qu'il est
associé au chiffre 1 et pourra pas
lancer là c'est la catégorie du coup
agriculteurs exploitant notre deuxième
catégorie c'est la catégorie donc le
chiffre deux artisans commerçants et
chefs d'entreprise
donc on va lui donner un petit coup un
petit concours artisans commerçants et
chefs d'entreprise des abandons artisans
commerçants et chefs d'entreprise
mais ensuite la troisième catégorie
correspond aux cadres et professions
intellectuelles supérieures donc un
encours
je prends je restais sur du catelet
train donc que donc les cadres on va
mettre le nom qui est donc cadres et
professions intellectuelles supérieures
nôtre
catégories suivantes ce sont les
professions intermédiaires et on avait
donné comme long cours
ep instant professions intermédiaires la
catégorie suivante ce sont les employés
la catégorie suivante ce sont les
ouvriers donc pour pour elle ça ça va
correspondre aux codes 1 ça ça
correspond au co2 ça va correspondre
octroie aux codes 4 au 25 au code 6 et
comme vous voulez lui dans cette enquête
a été rajoutée pour le coq haakon vii
pour la partie études inconduite qui
correspond aux périodes d'inactivité et
1 co 9 qui correspond au service
militaire
et donc si j'exécute ceci j'ai
maintenant d'objets label ce jeu vous
pourrez donc c'est un vecteur textuel
nommé donc j'ai des noms qui sont le
label proprement dit puis les petits
noms courts auxquels je peux accéder
avec l'ex de la baisse qui permet
d'avoir parce que suivre les sorties
parfois on aura besoin quelque chose de
cours un peu compact plus facile à
afficher parfois on veut avoir du coup
de taille complet ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que sur traminer lorsqu'on va
définir notre objet de séquences on va
pouvoir donner
en fait on va les finir plus
spécifiquement ce qu'on appelle un
alphabet l'alphabet du coup c'est ce
qu'il est utilisé pour coder ici les les
éléments dans les données et les données
sont codées numériquement sur la forme
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 et puis on va avoir
des étiquettes courte et les étiquettes
longue un objet de séquences se définit
avec la fonction sec def
donc nous allons créer en fait un objet
de séquences avec 5,9 on va lui passer
tout d'abord les données qui vont servir
donc là de données en fait ce sont
toutes les variables de csp 1 a cédé 37
donc je vais prendre de neige je fais un
select de csp un csp 37
je retire en fait la variable génération
je suis pas obligé si je je je vais
indiquer l'alphabet utiliser qui sont
ici les chiffres 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ça
serait pas obligé sinon dans ce cas là
c'est le débat prend directement toutes
les valeurs qui sont observés aux
dangers de données et je peux indiquer
states qui est un vecteur optionnel qui
contient à une étiquette courte
mais de 2 mai et a donc mes différents
et à 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 donc la version
courte ici on l'a vu ces names de la
belle et je peux aussi donner je ne me
trompe pas la baisse un autre vecteur
qui lui optionnel qui permet d'avoir des
étiquettes longue notamment pour les
graphiques alors exécutons cela donc
vous avez tout d'abord un résultat qui
vous affichez dans la consonne d'accord
qui me dit voilà on a un alphabet qui
est alors de 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 des labels
cours qui sont incrits caceis en fait
c'est ce qu'on a qu'on a on a donné
et puis des étiquettes longue on a
fourni
nous avons mille séquence dans le jeu
donné c'est à dire qu'on a bien mis
l'individu et puis on nous a dit qu'à
longueur des séquences alors là ya pas
de valeur manquant dans l'exemple on a
aujourd'hui on le verra quand on prend
une analyse de trajectoire ce qui se
passe lorsqu'on peut avoir des données
manquantes des trajectoires de longueur
inégale
là on a bien les trajectoires complexes
à interroger que des hommes qui avaient
atteint 1 h 50 ans et dont le voyez là
c'est que la longueur des séquences à
dire le monde d'état qui composent une
séquence est ici de 37 pour tous les
individus ans minimum et ans maximum la
caisse
qui se pose maintenant c'est comment
nous allons toutes ces séquences
individuel c'est est ce que il ya des
gens qui ont finalement des trajectoires
professionnelles qui se ressemblent tout
l'intérêt de l'analyse séquence va être
d'essayer de repérer si certains
individus ont des trajectoires plus ou
moins similaires et donc du coup ce
qu'on va essayer de faire c'est une
classification hiérarchique pour
regrouper les individus en fonction de
la similarité entre leur séquence la
question c'est comment calculer une
similarité entre séquences et si vous
vous souvenez de la session consacrée à
la classification ascendante
hiérarchique
on a le besoin du coup de calculer une
distance entre individus et toute la
question c'est comment fait-on pour
calculer une distance entre eux c est
pour ça on va avoir recours et technique
qui s'appelle l' appariement optimale ou
qui veulent matching et cette méthode
consiste pour chaque paire de c quand
donc si on prend deux séquences côte à
côte a compté le nombre minimal de
modifications qu'il faut faire subir à
ces séquences pour tenir l'autre
par exemple supposons qu'on est trois et
a abaissé d'un individu qui a une
séquence a à bbb et à notre individu
qu'à la séquence à bb en fait pour
passer de la première séquence à la
deuxième séquence
il suffirait de supprimer le premier à
puis de rajouter 1 à la fin pourra
passer de l'un à l'autre et donc du coup
en fait on va contre conques on se voit
un coût de modification de la séquence
dans la version la plus classique et
celle que l'on va faire aujourd'hui on
considère que ajouté un état ont retiré
un état coûte 1 et que a
replacé un statut par un autre coûte 2
puisque c'est l'équivalent de je retire
quelque chose et je rajoute quelque
chose dans ce cas là la distance entre
ces deux séquences va tout simplement de
2 il me faut un ça va me coûter 1 pour
retirer le premier à et ça va coûter à
pour retirer pour ajouter un a à la fin
on pourrait avoir une autre situation on
aurait un individu qui serait à b d et
qui auraient sinon et un deuxième qui
seraient abaissés b débat en fait c'est
d'outragé c21 ces deux séquences se
ressemblent il suffirait en fait de
remplacer de transformer le b pensé et
je voulais dit par défaut on va
considérer un coût de 1,2 pour faire la
substitution
ce qui serait équivalent à dire je
retiens mais ça me coûte 1 je rajoute un
c'est ça coûte 2 pour vous montrer un
autre exemple de c'est vraiment là je
vous propose je vous ai mis aussi en
lien un article j'ai écrit dans plos one
alors qu'ils étaient sur le deuil de
l'anel il analyse la dynamique des
participations dans un observatoire
démographique qui fait les délices de
séquences ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est
de vous montrer une des figures de cet
article ou en présente cette technique
cette figure là donc là vous avez sur ce
graphique l'un deux individus donc là
ici n'est pas tant ce sont des rounds
enquête
d'accord ce qu'on va regarder c'est à
chaque enquête à ce que les personnes
ont été contactées et ont accepté de
participer contacter on refuse de
participer ou on n'ont pas été contactés
donc ici nous avons à la fable iii let
crpn
vous avez ici un premier individu dont
la séquence est crc ncrc
et un deuxième don à la séquence va être
rnc rnr
et si vous avez un petit fou entre les
deux donc une séquence d'une longueur 7
une séquence de longueur 6 le k1 par
défaut qui est la technique où on va
considérer un coup d'insertion ont un
coût de retrait de bain et un coup de
substitution de taux de 2
ça correspond à un cas particulier de
l'optical matching qu'on appelle la
longueur comme un seul secteur où elle c
est ce parce qu'en fait cela revient à
regarder lassouts séquence la commune la
plus longue
ici si vous regardez ces deux séquences
toutes les deux contiennent la secte
l'asu séquence fncl ici avec un petit
saut mais on a bien r ncr est donc dans
ce cas là la distance qu'on a entre ces
deux séquences et la longueur de la
première plus sa langueur de la deuxième
moins deux fois la longueur de cette
sous séquence c'est à dire 7 puis 6 - 2
x 4 on obtient 5
ce qu'on peut avoir en fait c'est que
ses équivalents à dire je retire ce
c'est là je retire ce c'est là je retire
ce c'est là ça m'a coûté 3 puis je
rajoute à n
et je rajoute un air et donc ça m'a
raconté de en plus ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que même si lequel puis il va se
faire de manière automatique
ce qui est important à amiens c'est que
l'idée c'est que l'optimum matching va
nous donner une métrique pour dire
est-ce que deux séquences sont
semblables ou différentes mais ça va
nous permettre du coup qui a tellement
de cas de figures différentes pas de
l'avoir du coup de vent ce qui se passe
donc revenons ici que non nous avons
juste créé notre objet de séquences
d'accord qui s'appelle sac je veux si
vous voulez afficher à l'écran rice et
toutes les séquences individuel qui se
disent qu'ils se présentent donc il y en
a un grand monde donc ce qu'on va faire
ses calculs et un appariement optimale
d'accord et donc ça ça se fait avec la
fonction sec dist
alors ça permet de calculer la distance
donc lady similarités entre séquences
d'accord on prend un jeu de données et
puis on va prendre une méthode il ya
plusieurs méthodes qui sont là nos
petits bols matching alors après il faut
savoir qu'on peut avoir plein de
variations et de manière de faire et de
maîtrise des coûts
vraiment s'il ya un nouveau un élément
que je vous invite à lire si vous êtes
intéressés par les délices de séquences
c'est aller lire le le guide utilisateur
du package traminer il est écrit en
anglais et ce guide utilisateur qui fait
alors ça fait 129 pages mais mais en
fait on va vraiment vous expliquer
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une séquence une
séquence et à une séquence d'événements
les différentes manières de stocker
d'informations nous on informe à londres
qu'un vous avez en fait plein d'autres
manières de représenter les données et
beaucoup de temps est consacré sur les
modes de calcul des métriques
nous ce qu'on va faire c'est vraiment le
cas le plus classique c'est ce qu'on
appelle du coup the longest comme un
petit suspens et qui est un cas
particulier d'optimum imaging lorsque
l'ensemble des coûts de substitution
sont égales 1 2 et que les coûts
d'insertion et de suppressions sont
illégales donc c'est vraiment
l'hypothèse par défaut et donc si vous
n'êtes pas quoi faire parts et sur cette
hypothèse là et donc sur la méthode
longest commons qui coince nous verrons
quand on fera l'analyse de deux
trajectoires de santé un de parcours de
soins comprend verra dans les prochaines
semaines on sera dans un cas un petit
peu différent ou en fait on peut
ordonner les états et dans ce cas là ça
peut être intéressant de partir plus tôt
sur la maîtrise du coût hiérarchisé et
donc on va personnaliser notre matrice
du coup donc on reverra un exemple
complexe
retenez qu'à cette étape le plus simple
c'est de là les hypothèses de base ou ne
considère peut remplacer un statut par
un autre c'est la même chose parce que
ça revient à dire la méthode par défaut
c'est que remplacer agriculteurs
artisans c'est la même chose que de
remplacer agriculteurs par employés ont
fait une hypothèse que tous les états se
valent et que remplacer un état par un
autre état coûte la même chose pour
calculer les distances
donc cette méthode l'un qui est le cas
par défaut c'est la méthode dite lcn son
langage commun sauf sequans qui
correspond je vous rappelle au cas où
tous les coups sont constants et il ya
là deux pour les coûts de substitution
et où les coûts d'insertion suppressions
sont égales à 1 et donc dans ce cas là
le calcul des distances se fait très
simplement
donc on va faire la matrice est distant
[ __ ] les insectes programme pour optimale
matching donc j'applique sec 10
je lui passe mon objet de séquences sac
et j'indique une méthode est ici j'ai
dit simplement lcs le calcul est en
train de se faire et donc on nous
présente un petit nombre d'informations
voyez nous avons mille séquence en tout
1000 observations avec neuf un statut
différent comme j'ai pris la méthode acs
et d'un voyez ça nous a fait une matrice
de substitution du coût unitaire de ces
quelque chose tout simple j'ai ici une
statistique qui médit sur l'once en
demis et quand sur l'a8 118 différentes
envoyé 818 trajectoires différentes
n'aurait pas pu les traités
individuellement
d'où l'intérêt d'essayer du coup les
regrouper ensemble et donc le temps de
calcul a été ici de 4,5 secondes ce qu
on a donc du coup d'autres exemples en
cinq ans même si je la fiche à l'écran
vous allez voir c'est en fait une
matrice donc là c'est pas très lisible
ici une matrice de
me ligne et mille colonnes c'est une
matrice de coût tout à fait ce qu'on
avait vu dans l'analyse à factorielle et
donc du coup maintenant qu'on a ses
distances la et ben on va pouvoir
calculer d'andrew g
alors ce qu'on va faire ce qui se passe
c'est que c'est quand même
l'actuel mance et c'est juste une
matrice on va les remplacer on va juste
se transforme en un dj patrice de
distance ce qui serait tout simplement
avec la fonction à se disent tu donc si
jamais je dis je rajoute juste un petit
as 10 titien pourquoi du coup le
résultat soit pas juste une matrice mais
qu'on a dit c'est une matrice de
distance et donc du coup maintenant
l'objet c'est quand même c'est un objet
qui a la classe dit ce qu'ils disent est
une matrice dos distance en particulier
et pour calculer notre programme où on
va faire du coup un arbre j'ai appelé
cet arbre à ça se fait tout simplement
[Musique]
avec la fonction hqe lost que nous
avions déjà vu donc je vais appeler h
clust à qui je passe ma matrice de
distance et on va indiquer la méthode et
comme on l'avait fait pour la
classification énergie qu'on va tout
simplement partir sur la méthode de ward
avec les distances passé au carnet ward
points des deux donc là je vous réfère à
la cession du webinaire consacrées à la
planification à 50 hiérarchique et si je
regarde rapidement là que j'ai obtenu un
donc la boue
voyez si je fais un zoom la de
classification qui a été fait donc on
voit quand même se séparer donc la ccl
graphique très vite un pas forcément
très propre on voit bien quand même
qu'il ya un certain nombre de grandes
séparation il donc la question va devoir
accomplir le groupe
on va couper mais on a quand même bien
là juste à l'oeil une première catégorie
ici dans cette branche là probablement
qu'on doit pouvoir en prendre une ou
deux et puis peut-être couper ici
également alors la question c'est si
jamais je coupe par là ça nous ferait
une deux trois quatre et cinq
après avoir ou se faire on se fait le
découpage
on peut aussi regarder du coup à l'eso
d'inertie un donc je vous le rappelle on
va faire un graphique très très rapide
mais pour cela si on veut représenter
les sons d'inertie elle édite un premier
graphique de l'arbre pour les sondés
merci on peut reprendre du coup notre
arbre on prend la août les dimanches les
différentes hauteurs de l'arbre on va
trier ça une manière décroissante
on va en prendre que les 20 premières
valeurs qu'il faut qu'elle fasse là là
je prends les dix premiers alors je
prends les 20 premières valeurs
oui j'ai mon vécu là en fait avec cet
arbre d'accord ait je prends une ou des
auteurs des différentes branches
je les trie de manière décroissante
je prends les 20 premières et unsa
on l'a fait un trafic
alors voici graphique le retient par des
fois là on est vraiment sur des
graphiques rapplique qui sont faits avec
r mais je faire type égale s pour un
graphique de type step
alors ça il n'y a pas besoin de le
connaître par coeur je vous avoue à
chaque fois que j'ai besoin de faire ce
graphique la vie de fait je vais sur
site analyse r je regarde l'exemple ils
pigent adapte les gens copient
mais si je fais un zoom sur ce graphique
on voit les sauts d'inertie
effectivement 5 pour être une des
coupures
peut-être qu'on aurait pu descendre un
petit peu à d'autres endroits
je vais m'arrêter sur cinq classes parce
que cinq classes c'est le nombre 2e de
classe qu'elle est ravie que la retraite
dans son analyse
donc je vais partir sur celle ci pour
récupérer la partition d'accord donc là
j'ai découpé en 5
si je fais quelques cheveux secs arbres
car égale 5
j'obtiens directement la partition en
cinq classes ce que je vais faire je
vais sauvegarder ça donc je vais appeler
sa secte pour le parc pour ma partition
et je veux en même temps le transformer
en un facteur et dont je rappelle mes
différents niveaux ça sera un 2.5
mais je vais leur mettre des étiquettes
ça sera pas ce temps le mot passe est un
point ça alors peut-être que là je suis
en train de perdre si vous prenez jeu
cet élément là un poste c'est la
fonction qui permet de conques athénée
des chaînes de texte si je fais classe
que je veux concrétiser avec le vecteur
12.45 j'obtiens le vecteur classes une
classe de classe 3 classes 4 à 5
tout simplement donc là ce que l'on fait
ici
la volée d'accord je récupère ma
partition et la transforme en un vecteur
en un facteur mais j'ai directement
nommés mais quinze classes une classe
doute las trois passes quelques à 5 pour
avoir quelque chose d'un tout petit peu
plus ou alors on voit qu'on a cinq
groupes
si je fais un tableau de fréquence de ma
partition on voit du coup qu'on a cinq
types de trajectoire mais ça serait bien
conseillé de comprendre un point
correspondre une première classe qui
représente 36% la population ou 2e
classe 18% une classe 3 à 10% une
cascade 29 à 2,6 et l'a5 représentent 50
à un individu maintenant on va essayer
de caractériser ces différentes classes
lie à quoi ça correspond
là on va déjà ce qu'on vend aujourd'hui
ce sont les différentes représentations
graphiques qui sont disponibles avec le
mac est ravie ne et vous verrez on
refera quand on abordera les
trajectoires de santé des
représentations graphiques qui elles
vont exploiter gg bloc 2 pour pouvoir
représenter aussi ce qu'on va appeler
les tapis de cérences alors renier un
graphique possible c'est ce qu'on
appelle les creusot cram ou lester
distribution pelote cela s'obtiennent
avec saic dit lot de la fougue de trois
mineurs je lui passe mon objet de
séquences si j'en fais juste mon objet
de séquences on y est déjà
en fait on va voir que ses fonctions
graphiques peuvent être utilisés avant
même qu'on ait fait une partition je
vais faire un zoom du graphique obtenu
donc ce graphique nous représente
alors le problème c'est toujours la
légende qui s'affiche pas toujours bien
qu'ils graphique
[Musique]
avec des graphiques qui sont gérés dans
par très mineures mais alors ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est classe qu'on
représente c'est à chaque pas tant donc
ce sp1 sp2 et sp3 dans le chacune de ces
pactes en la distribution de la
population par rapport à 2 2 fait à ce
que je vais pouvoir faire c'est le faire
séparément pour les différents des
tables jeu mais faire groupe égal c'est
parti ennahdha les gens de sa fiche mal
je pense parce qu'on a des labels trop
long ce que je vais faire je vais garder
les labels cours tout du long
je refais mon objet ce que je vais faire
ici voyez quand je définis mon objet sec
je vais changer les étiquettes pour
avoir des labels cours je les gardais le
label court j'ai pas mais tu es label
long et on va refaire le graphique
l'avantagé du coup tout va bien
s'afficher
si on veut vraiment faire des graphiques
très très beau très très proches en fait
on a intérêt à passer un moment donné à
une étape ultérieure angers pelote et ça
je vous montrerai du coup un petit peu
plus tard
est-ce qu'on voit du coup on a presque
notre graphique final donc voyez là en
ayant rajouté le paramètre sec par
groupe france havas fait un saut
graphique par son groupe
et puis dernier élément qu'on va
rajouter dans le graphique
il ya un des paramètres de sacs diplôme
qui s'appelle x tellab permis des
étiquettes pour l' axe horizontal et je
vais remplacer les csp 1 2 par les
chiffres 14 à 50 juste parce que du coup
ça va nous permettre de représenter les
différents âges
donc là ce qu'on voit c'est la
distribution de la population à chaque
acteur d'accord donc ce que l'on voit
c'est que dans la casud à l'âge de 14
ans la majorité des individus
son nom est un verbe sont en fait
étudiants et un petit nombre sont
ouvriers
on va voir qu'avec le temps ils sont de
moins en moins nombreux à être étudiant
l'appart ouvriers laisse à peu près
équivalente
on a une par la hongrie celles et ceux
qui font le service militaire plutôt
entre du coup 19 et 22 ans et plus après
une majorité vont devenir en position
rouge donc en passer en professions
intermédiaires
donc on a une partie de gens qui sont
rayés a difference talent mais une
grande majorité va être plutôt dans les
professions intermédiaires et on voit qu
une partie va même devenir cadres à
partir de 36 ans donc ça c'est la
distribution c'est comme si je faisais
un histogramme dans la distribution des
statuts à chaque temps on voit que la
classe 2 pour sa part ce alors on a
toujours le phénomène un petit peu
d'étudiants 1 au jeune âge un effet
service militaire visible entre 18 et 24
ans et la majorité d'entre eux vont être
ouvrier à chacun on lkp lutte ouvrière
la classe 4 beaucoup d'étudiants début
d'un service militaire qui s'étale plus
dans le temps et envoie une sortie
d'études tardive et la majorité va
passer cadre donc certains vont
peut-être répond à un temps en position
intermédiaire mais voyez la majorité
qu'à tout du long
donc là on a une ou même catégorie
personnes qui vont faire des études
longues et vont avoir des statuts cadres
professions supérieures
ici la place numéro 5 non se sont du
coup pareil honda étude des passages en
vrille et mais ce qui va dominer même si
ça augmente de manière progressive c'est
d'être dans une dans une trajectoire qui
va être dominée par les professions
artisans a cessé d'être au point et
chefs d'entreprise il y est donc
le premier graphique représente du coup
la distribution des individus de la
classe un âge donné par rapport à ces
états ce que ça ne vous dit pas c'est à
quel moment les gens changent lancé
juste la distribution un chacun à chacun
des âges et donc du coup ce qui peut
être intéressant c'est de représenter
plutôt dans ces cas là des tapis de
séquences le tapis de séquences on va
garder l'information au niveau
individuel on va représenter chaque
individu sa trajectoire personnelle
alors le tapis de séquences lui pas se
faire à la va être la fonction sec
yp lot avec un i majuscule
alors c'est un graphique et un petit peu
plus long à s'afficher et on va zoomer
donc le principe d'accord chaque ligne
représente un individu est ce que l'on
voit c'est l'évolution de sa trajectoire
personnelle donc là vous avez tout
emballé un premier individu d'accord qui
a commencé en statue vient donc il était
étudiant
puis il passe en rouge quelques temps
donc il est temps professions
intermédiaires puis les parties faire
son service militaire en algérie et
après il est repassé en professions
intermédiaires comment quelques temps
pour redevenir cadre donc là on voit
toutes les trajectoires individuelles
petit défaut de cette représentation
graphique qui fait par traminer c'est
que tous les graphiques ont la même
hauteur mais pas tous forcément le même
nombre d'individus la classe 4 ici ce
sont 2 196 individus qui se représentait
la casse une ce sont 300 66 alors que la
classe soldes c'est simplement cinquante
et une personnes et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que sûr c'est qu'à 5 c'est
parfois un peu cool is it parce que
chaque trajectoire individuelle a
représenté avec plus d'épaisseur de
trait un individu de samba il a commencé
à être étudiant puis orange il était
ouvrier à l'âge de 18 ans à 19 ans il
est en service militaire mais il y
apparaissait longtemps à 20 ans ils
étaient de nouveaux ouvriers et à 30 ans
il est devenu en professions
intermédiaires
il est même passé il est patient foyer à
l'âge de 34 ans jusqu'à 30 septembre et
à 38 ans il est passé artisans chefs
d'entreprise
donc là cette augmentation là elle est
un petit peu plus compliqué parce que du
coup il faut arriver à la lire et en
même temps elle est plus précise parce
qu'on voit toutes les trajectoires
individuelles des individus est donc là
nous avons du coup ici ce qu'on va
appeler les tapis de séquences qui est
vraiment là une des représentations les
plus intéressants sauf que ducros les
tapis de séquences peut-être parfois ce
qu'on peut améliorer c'est dans quel
ordre représente les individus là les
individus sont représentés simplement
dans l'ordre du fichier et parfois pour
améliorer la lecture des petites
séquences qu'on est il de changé
lambeaux une des manières automatisé de
changer l'ordre
c'est de passer ce qu'on appelle du
multi dimensional scaling
et en fait on il ya une fonction qui
s'appelle la fonction cnds qui en est
qui permet juste de trier les individus
un petit peu différemment pour ça on va
prendre notre matrice de distance qui
est donc cet om d'accord et on va lui
passer la fonction celle des skieurs en
disant qu'à et ghana on va juste les
ordonnée selon un axe et je vais stocker
le résultat dans une barrière que je
vais appeler ordre en fait ça on va
exécuter avant le ces qui pelote et donc
dans le sait qui pelote
on peut indiquer un tri verticale en les
passant c'est vrai or donc en fait ce
que fait ordre ça donne juste un regard
des ordres ça va juste trier les
individus le les positionner les uns par
rapport aux autres
en fait selon un axe mais ça va
permettre juste pour ce qui nous
intéresse ici quand on fait à notre
graphique des tapis de séquences de
pouvoir un peu mieux trier voiliers du
coup on gagne un petit pont lisibilité
parce que certaines séquences très
similaire au est du coup classer les
unes à côté des autres
là par exemple sur la case de on voit
que l'effet durée d'étude 1 on se
retrouve avec ce conseil le plus
d'années d'études classé en haut est ce
que l'on fait le moins classé en bas
voilà tout ça ce sont des éléments qui
vont permettre de faciliter la lecture
et la présentation des différentes
habite séquence
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que quand on
fait des analyses de cinq ans il n'y a
pas de classification miracle une grosse
partie du travail ça va être pour vous
de faire un travail vraiment
sociologiquement classification
hiérarchique ou analyse factorielle de
bien visualiser les classes plein de
liens et de prendre le temps de bien
écrit et bien comprendre ce qui s'y
passe
alors une autre manière de trier ce qui
pourrait être intéressant vu qu'on a
fait une classification ça serait
pouvoir représenter ce tapis de
séquences ordonné en fonction du
d'andreu g de lard de classification
qu'on a fait et pour ça il ya une
fonction qui s'appelle sac quatre maps à
une fonction que j'ai développé
personnellement que j'avais d'ailleurs
misé sur internet et dans un petit
package personne qui n'est pas sur le
croec était repris d'ailleurs dans un
ouvrage dans un package ducron qui
s'appelle 50 book qui est un petit
package qui accompagne un ouvrage dédié
à nice de séquences et donc du coup
c'est accessible directement maintenant
sur crans donc on va charger la la
librairie 7l book que vous aurez
installé bien sûr auparavant sur votre
machine
du coup maintenant vous pouvez appeler
la fonction sec et map ce qu'on va lui
passer c'est d'abord notre objet de
séquences puis le don programme qu'on
appelait sec pour un arbre
éventuellement d'étiquettes
alors ici le pas rappellent s'appelle la
pole là je vous montre les codes mais
n'oubliez pas à chaque fois qu'on veut
voir toutes les options de
personnalisation il faut la regarder
lettre de chacune des fonctions dont 14
50 pour améliorer la lecture
et voici le résultat
là en fait l'intérêt donc on retrouve
comme tout à l'heure nos séquences qui
sont qui sont représentés simplement
vous avez le tendre au grave du tout à
l'heure qui est représenté sur ce côté
gauche et donc du coup on fait alors
présent toutes nos catégories et ça
c'est un des graphiques hyper
intéressant lorsqu'on n'a pas encore
choisi le nombre de classes que l'on
veut faire parce que ça permet de voir
en fête ou où se situent les classes
si par exemple le tir était un simple on
avait voulu en faire six arrêts couper
cette grande classe là en deux à ce
niveau là et on verrait en fait que nous
aurions eu
donc ce groupe là qui est une partie
employés avec une et qui sont des gens
qui reste grosso monde ans dans l'état
rouge
donc si on fout liens du code couleur et
tout à l'heure à inquiéter les
professions intermédiaires alors que là
on a en fait ici dans ce groupe-là de
sous type de trajectoire qui pourrait
être même être divisée en deux si on se
mettait ici dans ce groupe là en fait
ici est ce qu'on voit ce sont des gens
qui ont des trajectoires qui sont plutôt
études professions intermédiaires et
passage cadre ici en violet alors que
dans ce groupe là on va aller voir des
plus tôt orange communes sont bienne ce
sont des gens qui sont plutôt sur une
transition ouvriers professions
intermédiaires en tout cas ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça m'aide vraiment
voir avec ce graphique l'impact 1 du
choix de nos catégories ce qui se passe
et si on prend beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de catégories
diagramme de catégorie on va avoir des
classes qui vont être plus homogène mais
qui vont concerner un tout petit nombre
de gens et on va avoir un très grand
nombre de classes donc après le poison
ivy ça peut devenir compliqué notamment
si on regarde les facteurs associés à
une classe faire un modèle multi
nauviale ou est-ce qu'on veut un nombre
plus restreint de classe mais donc du
coup forcément on va perdre du détail
puisqu'on va agréger les individus qui
peuvent être un petit peu un petit peu
différent
alors une autre manière de procéder
sectionnelles est ce qu'on peut faire un
petit
est ce qu'on peut faire un tapis de
séquences avec gégé bloc 2 pour rendre
les choses de manière un petit peu plus
visible est un peu plus et un peu plus
un peu plus agréable alors je vais vous
montrer comment procéder mais ça va nous
demander de faire un petit peu de
manipulation de données d'une part pour
pas me perdre on va avoir besoin d'avoir
un identifiant dans le nôtre jeux de
données
donc je vais créer une variable idée
d'accord qui met tout simplement 1 à
1000 watts consommés ligne dont 1000
lignes en fait c'est le nombre de lignes
qui adore donner donc en faisant ça je
vais juste numérotée méline ça me
servira à identifier
deuxièmement je vais garder aussi la
classe donc je prends la variable
j'écris de variables classe dans mon jeu
de données dans lequel je vais
sauvegarde et du coup à ma partition qui
était cette partie
et puis ce que je veux faire j'aimerais
garder du coup l'ordre donc 1er 2e 3e 4e
en fait c'est donc cette somme ce
vecteur ordre je vais que je vais
conserver mais si sauf que ce vecteur là
en fait on fait mine les valeurs qui
nous permettent de les trier mais
séparément un ordre de moi quelle est la
première la deuxième et la troisième
dans ce dans cet élément là donc j'ai
plutôt avoir envie d'avoir quelque chose
qui est de dire c'est le plan un rang
ordonné qu'elle serait là là quelle va
être la trajectoire que jean
représentant 1 en deux ans croit pas ce
qu'on va me servir de coordonner sur la
kz2 y pour faire mon tapis de séquences
du coup ce que je vais faire au lieu de
prendre la variable ordre vais plutôt en
faire un un rang d'accord je l'utilisé
où l'anc dans ce cas là les valeurs
pourraient ordonner un deux trois quatre
cinq six sept et je veux pas avoir de
nouvelles ont donc jusqu'à rouge et
précisé ties méthodes et garonne
d'hommes c'est à dire que si jamais il y
avait deux de ligne qui avait la même
valeur de ordre on va leur donner un
ordre direct et donc si je regarde
maintenant ce que j'obtiens dans l'ordre
alors ce que j'obtiens c'est plutôt à un
rang d'affichage plutôt que la valeur
qu'on avait lu cm 10 kg 1 j'ai donc ici
maintenant un jeu de données
on l'a vu c'est un jeu de données au
format large 1 g une colonne par un
parent pas de temps l'idée pour faire
mon tapis de séquences dans danger
pelote c'est que finalement mais est
assez des ti rectangle que je vais
afficher avec l'ingestion x et puis mon
rang mon ordre finalement on y est c'est
comme ça je vais reproduire du coup ce
type de représentations graphiques
sauf que pour faire un graphique j'ai
peur j'ai besoin d'un fort mal long
c'est à dire un format où j'ai une ligne
par petit rectangle de couleur et pour
ça du coup il va nous falloir passer par
pivote longueur du package talent hier
on l'a déjà vu un pilote rider pivote
longueur qui permet de faire ces
manipulations
donc je vais charger aussi en mémoire
taille d'hier là je veux passer d'un
format large d'un format long donc c'est
pivote longueur le nom de la fonction et
on va les regarder
l'aide de pivot de longues heures pour
être sûr de voir comment est ce que noah
l'indiqué donc mon format long ça va
être donc partir de données pivote
longueur alors les colonnes on va passer
un nous les colonnes qu'on va
transformer le format nous à ce format
large les colonnes du coup ce sp1 donc
corse et du coût de ce sp1 à csp 37
alors je vais juste faire un test est ce
que ça va changer la syntaxe est correct
mais ce qu'on va faire c'est que
je vais considérer je vais stocker les
résultats de noms des colonnes ce sp1
sp2 donc née une sts ou dans des
colonnes je vais en faire une valeur que
je vais appeler que j'appelais années et
les valeurs du coup on va l'y nous
q- csp il faut que je remette entre
guillemets c'est le nom la colonne je
vous montre à quoi ressemble cet objet
van long d'envoyer long maintenant un
biais de 37000 ligne puisque j'ai une
ligne pour chaque année pour chaque
individu et donc du coup j'ai bien ma
génération qui est resté les
identifiants la classe en fait les
variables qui était pas mise en rang et
la variable ordre elles sont du coup
répéter pour tous les individus
toutes les lignes de l'individu 1 et
voyons là année csp un essai s p 1 1 et
les valeurs des codes de csp alors il va
nous falloir encore faire un tout petit
peu de transformation premièrement on a
du coup l'on csp qui ne verraient le
numérique et moi j'ai transformé en
facteur donc long csp je la reconnais et
dont le dire que c'est un facteur de
long csp les niveaux à prendre c'est
donc les valeurs à 1,9 et les la baisse
je les ai j'ai déjà stocké tout à
l'heure dans un geste ok ça dans la
baisse
si je regarde longue voyez c'est
maintenant un csp est devenu un facteur
avec meetic est l'enquêté
ce que je vais faire on assez sp1 sp2 et
sp3 moi j'aurais bien récupérer la
question âge alors si je prends long
années déjà je pourrai récupérer un
numéro en supprimant les trois premières
ce que j'aimerais c'est supprimer csp
donc garder uniquement la partie le
texte qui suit pour ça il faut utiliser
les fonctions esther de stringer alors
et nous avons notamment str seul qui est
la fonction qui permet de d'extraire une
partie est personne c'est pour supprimer
une partie d'une chaîne de caractère
avec et donc si je dis je prends moins
neige et je fais str seul
vous avez préparé questar qu'il ya
partir où on doit prendre et si je dis
start égale qu'un c'est à dire à partir
du 4e caractère voyez ce que j'obtiens
c'est l'échelle 1 2 3 4 j'ai gardé en
fait les j'ai juste supprimer la partie
cspc chaîne de textes cela je peux les
transformer en nombre entier
donc si je fais azentek heures je
récupère des chiffres on a vu que c'est
sp1 correspondait à l'âge de 14 ans csp
37 correspondait l'âge de 50 ans donc on
va t'il je rajoute 13 si je rajoute 13
ans j'ai déjà stocké ça si je prends
tout ça et que je rajouterais j'obtiens
directement mon âge
lorsque je peux mettre le plus très ici
un terrain de syntaxe voilà donc j'ai
rajouté mon 13 les voyez j'ai bien du
coup 14-15-16 saint quentin pour chaque
individu et tout ça je vais le stocker
dans une barrière que j'ai appelé long h
j'ai donc du coup une variable âge qui
contient tout simplement qui contient du
coup la gc ca qui a observé qu'on a
quitté x gma mariable ordre qui est une
variable qui contient à mon axe
d'imposition sur l' axe d y d'accord et
je vous la représenter ça pour chaque
individu
juste une petite subtilité alors j'en
fais un point on va faire le premier
graphique rapidement pour voir ce que ça
donne si je fais ggp lot
donc je prends mon fichier non en x
je vais représenter du coup h1y je vais
représenter
c'est ma position verticale c'est pour
ça que j'en ai besoin c'est ce qui va me
permettre de faire le tweak
je vais dire que je remplis en termes de
couleurs avec mon statut qui s'adresse
csp est ce qu'on va faire c'est à pied
j'ai eu mon master qui permet en fait de
faire infléchir la surface des petits
rectangles uns à côté des autres
on va faire un zoom et voyez on pourrait
retravailler sur le sur le type de le
type de palettes de couleurs sur vous
nous voyez j'ai à peu près fait fait les
éléments alors premiers éléments on va
déjà prendre un thème beaucoup plus
légers dont vous refaire thème b w
donc ça soit plus lisible je vais
changer quand même de couleur
on va prendre une des palettes brève
heures et on va prendre la palette 7 3
qui si je ne trompe pas de vrai un peu
près correspondent
je crois que c'est la panne est utilisé
par défaut par traminer on va faire le
zoom
effectivement c'est bien les mêmes codes
couleurs dont comprenant la palette 7 3
on retrouve là la palette que l'on avait
ce qui m'intéresserait l'accès y quand
on n'est pas vraiment bougé de l'affiché
parce qu'il n'est pas en l'occurrence là
il n'est pas n'est pas nécessaire par
contre j'aimerais bien voir mes
différentes classes et donc je vais
ajouter des facettes
donc si je fais face est oui et d'un
blouson égale vase de comme on
l'appelait je crois que la vraie classe
de classe
alors on obtient bien graphique
séparément pour chacune de mes classes
mais le problème c'est que voyez ma
variable or d'aller calculée sur le
global et donc j'ai pas les éléments
côte à côte ils sont pas tout à fait ce
qui m'intéresse d'accord ce qu'on va
faire
et la petite astuce que je veux montrer
c'est en fait on va passer la variable
ordre en un facteur donc je vais pas mal
performé facteur deux ordres
ça va devenir un facteur et dans bofa 7
je vais ajouter les options ce qui est
égal
oui y une série égale free y
la particularité c'est que quand on nous
dit que les échelles verticale avec free
grecs peuvent s'ajuster de l'un à
l'autre
quand il va le numérique il va juste
ajouter sur le minimum le maximum
donc c'est un facteur en fait ça va
supprimer les valeurs de l'observer et
vous voyez le résultat
on va faire un zoom là alors il ya
encore des éléments à améliorer le
niveau de présentation mais j'ai bien
trois graphiques
j'ai trois graphiques et sur ces trois
graphiques l'épaisseur toutes les lignes
en fait on avait à l'épaisseur et donc
du coup elle à la représentation des
classes est proportionnelle à leur
taille dans l'échantillon donc on a
vraiment quelque chose qui est qui et
plus plus plus à claudette alors on a
encore des petites améliorations qui
sont qui sont possibles par exemple ce
qui y est les ducs ou discrète que je
les passais en facteur phallus indiqué
l'appel égale nul pour dire je ne veux
pas afficher l'étiquette sur mon
accident
parce que ça ne fait pas sens et sur mon
axe dx donc je vais forcer le minimum et
maximum à 14 et 50 c'est moi qui vais
indiquer les coupures parce que les en
fait on a 1 14 qui vient perturber donc
en fait je veux faire 14 20 25 30 35 40
45 50
non c'est juste que tu qu'on sera pas à
15 ans sera à 14 pour bien représenter
notre minimum mais je le fais du coup en
manuel et puis pourrait vite
alors si je fais ça je vais vous montrer
à quoi ressemble notre graphique donc
j'ai bien fixer mon minimum mon maximum
on a bien les trajectoires qui sont
visibles est ce que je vais faire ça
c'est vraiment première étape 1 et on
pourrait donc on va aller plus loin je
pourrais supprimer par exemple le long
métrage ou supprimées en fait cette
étiquette labatut si un jour peut-être
mettre présenter mieux la légende en bas
à gauche mais voyez on a réussi à
reproduire mgg pelote un graphique un
tapis de séquences faut juste arriver à
bien définis en fait la variable
verticale qui nous coûte variable d'or
qui nous permet de trier et là on a
vraiment sur cette représentation
graphique là on voit bien le poids
inégale des différentes classes vraiment
puisque ici tous les individus sont bien
représentés avec la même épaisseur et on
voit du coup que ma classe une est bien
plus importante que ma classe 5 le
chiffre de change étiquette ou que je
fasse ainsi l points 5 pour une chose de
plus le plus joli mais on arrive quand
même à voir ici
ces poids différent et c'est tout le
travail qui est le vôtre est de bien
décrire votre votre phénomène
alors pour continuer sur la
représentation graphique ils sont
fournis avec traminer et qui servent
aussi quand même à explorer de donner à
la comprendre ce qui s'y passe
vous voyez c'est toujours c'est qu'une
lettre club nous avions vu le sexe des
pelotes qui était la distribution un
graphique qui peut être aussi
intéressant c'est le graphique de
fréquences qui présente pour chaque
classe les les dix séquences les plus
fréquentes
donc ici ce que nous montre ce graphique
est encore en train de de s'afficher
pour chacune de mes classes à
représentent les dix séquences unique
les plus fréquentes et ça nous indique
le pourcentage total donc ça permet de
voir l'or là on est sûr il ya beaucoup
de séquences unique donc ya pas
forcément de séquences qui sont beaucoup
de doublons sur d'autres villes donné ça
peut être un petit peu différent et ça
permet du coup d'avoir une idée quand
même des séquences un peu cheap et on
retrouve bien cette idée que la classe
de ce sont des gens qui sont sur un
parcours essentiellement de carrière en
tant qu'ouvrier ont presque tout au long
de leur vie
la question ce sont ceux qui ont fait
des études courtes durées moyennes les
études courtes sans classe ou en classe
froide ont placé les études moyennes en
place une suivi une profession
intermédiaire la classe 4 c'est ceux qui
ont un parcours est longue et puis
cadres et la classe iii ou va y trouver
des agriculteurs qui sont devenus
employés ou des employés au large ça
permet de voir au moins les classiques
une autre représentation qui vient
compléter ce que l'on avait pu voir tout
à l'heure avec la distribution à chaque
pack temps un autre élément qui peut
être intéressant mais aussi pour
réfléchir à à quel moment les plats sont
homogènes il faut présentes sont au même
niveau si leur se représenter la classe
modal à chaque pas tant donc ça s'est
proposé par saic ms pelote
donc si je vous fais le graphique sec
ms pour modeste et s
olemps ce calcul graphique donc ce
graphique là vous indique à chaque pas
de temps et ici dans chaque classe
là le statut modal c'est à dire le
statut le plus représenté est la hauteur
vous indique le poids de ce statut dans
l'échantillon quand on est proche de
celle que tout le monde est dans ce
statut là et parfois en ligne et moi
mais ça vous permet de générer une sorte
de parcours type de votre classe
donc on retrouve encore une fois eu le
même narratif à la classe une est une
moyenne service militaire deux ans puis
on part professions intermédiaires la
classe 4 ses études longues épreuves une
et et de une trajectoire professionnelle
en tant que cadre supérieur
donc c'est une autre manière aussi de
caractériser encore une fois n'oubliez
pas comme la distribution parfois ça
masque ce type de représentation est
intéressant parce que ça ça simplifie et
donc savourer d'aller un peu à
l'essentiel quand on a trop
d'informations mais n'oubliez pas que ça
à masquer du coût des parcours un peu
plus compliqué ça veut pas dire que les
gens passent de l'issic les gens passent
trois ans dans le service militaire et
qu'ils offraient un service média plus
lent que les autres c'est juste qu'en
fait c'est un petit peu plus répartis
dans la classe a donc soyez toujours
vigilants a bien apprêtée et pas
surinterpréter ce type de
représentations graphiques
vous avez aussi la fonction sec
mt lot ce que représente ce graphique
là c'est pour chacune des classes la
durée moyenne passée dans chacun des
états donc si on prend la durée moyenne
1 la casse une épave
la plus grande durée est passé dans
professions intermédiaires et puis après
il ya des petites ont passé en études
ouvriers cadres la classe 4a voyez c'est
surtout études et puis quatre autres du
lot la case de ses ouvriers donc vous
avez ici une statistique simplifier un
la durée moyenne passée dans chacun des
états feront d'être avec toi
la fonction sakr pelote pour sa part
alors et on va discuter du résultat
alors oui bon il faut pour ça car pelote
il faut fournir la dc la matrice de
distance j'oubliais donc liste magics
égalant du coup nous c'est quoi donc
c'est ken block qui a besoin qu'on lui
passe la matrice des distances sont
complets dont ce qu'elle cherche
je crois qu'un petit preuve de fichage
cherche à identifier les séquences
représentatives de chaque classe est ce
qu'on va essayer de relancer sein de
refaire un zoom
pourquoi ce n'est pas l'affiché
elle a un petit problème d'affichage
parce que je pense qu'il faut l'affiché
tout de suite en grand
du coup alain comme je suis comme je
partage l'écran et que du coup je réduis
ma taille d'écran ce que je vous propose
c'est de vous le montrer directement sur
le site en condition plus réel un ici
donc si on pour vous montrer le résultat
quand on le fait on est avec les mêmes
données
donc il s'agit de ce graphique là et je
vais le bel anglais qu'on puisse avoir
en grand donc je vous montre déjà pour
les premières classes
l'idée du cours de cette fonction-là la
fonction s'acquiert pelote
elle cherche à identifier les séquences
entre guillemets représentatives de
chaque classe
là plusieurs méthodes 1 qui sont
proposés on parle d'un délai pour voir
tout ce qui se passe là à défaut on peut
utiliser du coup avec la avec notre
matrice de distance la méthode distants
c'était de ça que je viens de mettre
dans mon code voilà pardon on est et où
je fais méthodes existent
malgré tout ça s'affiche pas très bien
donc je vais revenir sur l'exemple on le
verrait bien et quand vous travaillez
n'ont pas qu'un partage d'écran un ca se
présenteraient mieux donc l'idée quand
on la méthode ici si on gagne en fait
les séquences centrale sa classe
c'est-à-dire que quand on prend deux
classes on peut dans un nuage de points
calculé un pari sens de l'accueil de la
classe ils ont essayé de trouver la
classe la profession trouver une ou
plusieurs 20 ans que l'idée encore une
fois signifié trouver du coût des
critères une manière de présenter des
séquences qui sont un résumé de la
classe vous voyez pour la casse une il
en a trouvé un grand nombre qu'ils
peuvent y répondre
on a toujours où on voit quand même ces
périodes courtes souvent une attente que
l'arnacoeur des hommes de service
militaire
parfois un peu de temps pour passer
comme ouvrier avant ou après et puis une
carrière encore professions
intermédiaires
alors on va voir la casse 4 très
classique 1 la plus représentative c'est
s'est du coup études longues
une année thirith militaire et évite
précieux comme cadre avec un service
militaire qui à la fin des études
donc voilà c'est une des techniques pour
elle pourrait finir des montres traités
c'est intéressant justement à regarder
mais en ayant en tête le tapis de
séquences pour ça la voir de l'autre
côté
toujours pareil incident c'est la
vigilance qui est qui est requise pour
et pour éviter de
en fait c'est plutôt la comparaison
tient différents graphiques qui permet
d'avoir une bonne compréhension
au final de nos places un autre élément
qui est intéressant du coup c'est de
regarder l'entropie transversale qui est
une manière le décrit à l'évolution de
l'homogénéité d'une classe pour un jeune
est une entreprise proche de zéro
signifie que tous les individus de la
classe ou presque sont dans la même
situation
et quand l'entreprise est de 1 g
individus sont dispersés dans les
différentes situations pour faire ce
graphique là
on aura recours à la fonction sec
acheter pelote donc comprenons votre
code ici sec h majuscule t pelote
on va faire un zoom du graphique donc ce
qu'il faut retenir un c'est quand je
voulais dit quand les individus sont
proches l'entreprise est proche de zéro
c'est à dire que ces uniformes et quand
ça augmente vers un séquel la diversité
donc on voit que la classe 4 1 et très
uniforme au jeune zaz très uniforme
après 30 ans et qu'à la diversité entre
les individus entre 20 et 28 ans et si
on revenait au graphique à des
distributions
on doit avoir un qui était qui était
celui ci vous n'êtes qu'un fils
distribution voit effectivement que
c'est très uniforme après la avant 18
ans et très uniforme tourner dès l'école
après 30 ans est très uniforme tout le
monde travaille et puis à cette période
ou abandonner les gens vont arrêter
leurs études plus ou moins vite vont
faire un temps de service militaire et
donc du coup il ya un peu
d'hétérogénéité à ces âges là d'accord
et en fait ça se retrouve ici un puisque
ce sont les âges où l'entreprise est en
train d'augmenter
ça permet de voir aussi si certaines
classes sont plus homogènes que d'autres
moments où ça va changer
l'un
et bien d'autres délices séquence c'est
qu'on a produit finalement une typologie
une classe est en fait il faut voir ça
une fois qu'on a fait cette
classification comme une des étapes du
travail comme quand on a travaillé sur
la classification avanthier rares chic
c'est à dire comme étals de travail nous
avons sept cas cela donc l'intérêt
serait ensuite probablement de mieux
décrire la classe que l'on a donc le la
décrire ça threat croisé avec notre
variable par exemple nous avons une
variable génération et donc du coup est
ce que on pourrait charger gîte ismaily
et puis faire un tableau où elle est
donc je préfère donner select on va
regarder je faisais la seule variable
que j'ai vraiment à disposition
générations et classes faire un tableau
croisé ajouter une valeur aux 15 ans 1
j'ai fait un tableau croisé donc j'ai
pouvoir comparer les différentes classes
là par défaut monde à des pourcentages
qui sont colonnes et donc on peut voir
que alors ont trouvé cinq classes il n'y
a pas de gros effets et générationnelle
on and on parle de fusion des communes
paix valeurs qui à 0 en 18 on est en
dessous de 2% dont il ya quand même des
variations de table après le thé du qui
lui est assez sensible d'avignon du
nombre de cases ce qu'on peut voir c'est
que là peut-être qu'on pourrait avoir
plutôt les pourcentages en ligne aussi
ça serait avec personne et gao wei
après tout dépend ce qu'on voulait faire
pourcentage en colonnes si vous les
décrire qui est dans chaque classe
pourcentage en ligne si vous voulez voir
les gens contacter éric caractéristiques
dans quels cas s'ils vont plutôt à être
ce qu'on voit c'est que du coup la
génération il ya 146 1950 sont plus
représentés dans la classe une 1 que les
générations précédentes et que la classe
5 et plus tôt par contre cette fois ci
une classe qui est plus associé aux
générations précédentes donc on va voir
où et là des classes qui sont qui dans
le poids dont va augmenter avec les
générations jeunes et donc les emplois
va diminuer donc voilà vous pouvez
commencer à faire ce type de comparaison
la et si vous aviez tout un tas d'autres
caractéristiques comme le niveau d'étude
maximum atteint comme des clarines je
sais pas moi la région le milieu de
résidence
la csp des parents voilà on aurait un
cercle de choses qui permettrait de voir
si les trajectoires plutôt associé un
élément un autre et là on reste sur
l'analyse classique
autrement dit un des enjeux de neige aux
séquences ses 2,7 sous ce détail cette
complexité une trajectoire qui s'écoule
au cours du temps le pouvoir le ramener
à quelque chose de plus simple qui va
être une typologie typologique on va
pouvoir utiliser dans d'autres analyses
derrière soi comme une variable a
expliqué qu'on va s'y d'écrire pour
faire un modèle boutique familiale pour
voir les facteurs associés à ces classes
là ou bien comme variable pourra
utiliser comme variable explicative pour
expliquer notre phénomène qui nous
intéresse vous pouvoir essayer de
construire plusieurs trajectoires
différentes dimensions trajectoires
résidentielles trajectoire
confessionnelles trajectoire sanitaires
il voir comment elles vont s'articuler
les unes par rapport aux autres sachets
classe était vraiment une introduction
l'analyse de séquences pour vouziers de
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire quoi sert ce
type d'analyseur comme on voit ça une
sorte d'adaptation de l'analyse
génétique adapté au champ du social
vraiment je vous invite si vous êtes
intéressés
donc à aller voir les ressources
complémentaires le guide utilisateur du
package traminer un ce document d'une
centaine de pages est très très bien
écrit par l'équipe par l'équipe suisse
vous avez toutes les références du bio
qui sont nécessaires et ça vous donne
tous les enjeux un peu technique
derrière vous avez aussi l' ouvrage de
nicola roberts aux éditions du ceped le
centre population et développement
c'est un ouvrage 2011 mais qui est
encore intéressant qui s'appelle
explorer et décrire les parcours de vie
les typologies de trajectoire et le pdf
est disponible intégralement en ligne
donc du coup c'est un ouvrage que vous
pouvez récupérer et on est pareil sur un
ouvrage à beaucourt assez court un
ouvrage de 2 85 pages mais qui vous
présente toutes les grandes techniques
le tout le tout en demain en français et
comme je vous le disais par la suite
hélas avant l'été ce qu'on va les
aborder
c'est une analyse un peu plus poussée
alors c'est en fait je pense à nous
prendre plusieurs sessions qui vous
présentez un chapitre d'analyseurs qui
est trajectoire de soins donc ça c'est
un travail qui est adapté j'avais
préparé en fait pour un colloque sur
biographie et santé et en fait on va
prendre des données longitudinales sur
des trajectoires s'invite m mais qu'on
va explorer du coup avec différentes
techniques pour être sur un cas
contraire de données qui sont presque
réel et du lait tripatouiller pour les
en faire un fichier partageable mais on
va prendre le temps de décrire les
données dans un premier temps et puis
d'aborder en fait tout ça avec
différentes techniques d'analysé
certaine qu'on a vu d'autres on n'a pas
encore vu comme les modèles bxa crise
latente l'idée c'est de vous donner
voilà des pistes de réflexion ou voir
comment un même jeu de données vues avec
différentes techniques se présente
différemment apporte du coude et on
pourrait dire des regards
complémentaires et comment tout ça
un peut s'articuler donc je pense que
l'analyse des trajectoires de soins ça
va nous prendre facilement deux ou trois
séances et ce serait une manière aussi
de mettre en oeuvre tout ce qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent
sourit binaire retenait un les
webinaires on est vraiment plutôt sur
une introduction outil est pour vous et
les moyens ensuite d'aller chercher les
choses mais si quelque chose vous
intéresse il c'est à vous après d'aller
d'aller compléter d'aller creuser les
éléments qui nous sont nécessaires ne
voit qu'il ya pas deux je vois une
question qu'il arrive dans le ja til des
solutions pour faire de l'analyse
séquence si toutes les classes ne sont
pas remplies alors c'est quelque chose
qu'on va aborder dans cet exemple des
trajectoires de soins puisque on va
faire l'analyse de séquences avec les
trajectoires de longueur inégale
ça peut se faire ce qui se passe c'est
que qui le prennent quand les longueurs
des séquences sont très disparates
ça va faire des distances importantes
pour passer d'une séquence courte à une
séquence longue il faut rajouter des
statuts à la chaîne et donc du coup une
séquence courte et forcément éloigné
d'une séquence longue et donc le risque
c'est quand on fait une analyse aux
séquences avec des avec des séquences
qu'on ait longueur très inégale là vous
avez la cession des langueurs exprimé en
moi avec qui vont avec des longueurs de
un ou deux mois à des longueurs de 50
mois on voit en fait que on a plutôt des
regroupements séquences courtes versus
séquence yang
ce n'est pas forcément idéal lorsqu'on
veut mesuré dont les techniques ins et
là là d'un exemple on abordera enverra
koufra un autre analyse mais on va
apprendre que les gens observé 18 mois
et ont banalisé que 18 mois et ça permet
de revenir un cas de figure où les
variations entre séquences se sont pas
les preuves de longueur mais d'être
uniquement des problèmes de du phénomène
qui nous intéresse à une autre
possibilité à retenir c'est que on peut
aussi où on est obligé de faire non plus
des analyses de séquences de statut et
vous le verrez dans le monde
même de traminer on peut aussi analyser
des séquences d'événements dans ces cas
là ce qu'on regarde parce que quand on
travaille avec les statuts forcément la
séquence si on reste dix ans dans un
état puis on va changer sur un très tard
ou est ce qu'on regarde ça fait du coup
dans le statut mme b on va faire bb bb
bb b et ce qui peut nous intéresser
c'est peuvent d'un maul temps que l'on
passe dans un état ce qui nous menace et
que les transitions et on peut faire le
coup des séquences de transition ce
qu'on va à nos intérêts donc en fait
c'est comme si on supprimait le temps
passé pour garder à ge effet ab a alors
que l'autre a fait abaisser ce qu'on
regarde c'est que la transition d'un
état à l'autre et la succession de
transition mais c'est à dire tout net on
est intéressé par autre chose
encore une fois ça va dépendre du
phénomène qui nous intéresse on verra
dans l'analyse de trajectoire qu'on
abordera qui encore d'autres techniques
des modèles mixa classe là tant d'autres
des zones telles observations répétées
qui peuvent permettre de prendre en
compte pas les données des trajectoires
inégale en tôle ou en durée voilà sa
jambe qui a pas toujours de solution
unique et qu'on va et qu'on va faire du
coup un peu humble au cas par cas
on compterait ya vraiment un travail de
réflexion à avoir sur le type de données
que vous avez et sur les questions
voulais vous poser c'est pas des
solutions miracles en tout cas merci
aussi pour voir merci mots c'était voilà
une première
une première introduction et toutes
façons complètera prochainement
on va faire des exemples 1 et je pense
que c'est toujours par les cas concret
qu'on va avoir les choses les plus
intéressantes je vous dis en tout cas à
à bientôt et bats la semaine prochaine
du coup pour aborder un exemple concret
à partir de trajectoire de soins merci à
vous très bonne soirée
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions pour
ce et ceux qui sont replay sur l'espace
commentaires du site webinaire ou du
site analyseur qui sont les espaces pour
répondre aux questions vous posez
l'intérêt de passer par les commentaires
et non un petit mais l'amour direct
c'est que du coup vos questions et les
réponses que chez apporte bénéficiait
tout le monde merci à tous et à très
bientôt
au revoir